you see that Wesley's hand is a little
bit lovely and there you go the first
surprise Wesley head in his hands a
little laugh he's clearly shocked there
and it's one nil with a little smile as
well we talked about the English opening
the Dutch defense the French this is the
Portuguese opening and you nearly never
hear about it it's so rare it hits the
now this bishop look I love that he's
laughing he's laughing you can't believe
this move I mean again if if a pupil I
don't really teach him but if it people
of mine had played this move
I can't play Move letters
I think wow you can't keep it together
she's like I'm surprised and Wesley also
I think you can see him on camera
because Leslie's like oh like you're
laughing I'm laughing that he's got
Wesley thinking on move too how often do
you get Wesley thinking on mood too a
few moments later not a bag does just
resign and with that win a Wesley saw
takes the lead